well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Christina the shits
to your remember we went to get our Thai
massages yeah they were like hookers
after because you went to a different
one
what happened was we so we moved to a
new neighborhood and so we have to do is
to discover all kinds of new stuff again
right new restaurants everything you
used that's only you know it's kind of
fun but it's also you're like bummed out
if the place you used to go to you liked
yeah so we went to this Thai place
together like a few weeks ago and then
we went again and we called on the way
there to request the same people that we
had the first time well yours was
available for you but mine wasn't so I
go okay well I'll try whoever's
available so we finish the massage we go
to the lobby and the the lady that had
me the first time goes oh she goes yeah
last time I go yeah I asked for you and
she looked at the girl that just massage
and she goes yeah
yes for me and then she looked back at
me and she goes so next time you me
again and I was like oh okay
and the other lady you could tell that
she was higher up on the chain because
the the lady that had just massaged me
cat like put her head down I was like
uh-huh totally would cower to her you
just got involved in hooker wars dude
yeah Thai hooker whores hi well cars
massage hooker whoa yeah yeah they
totally she had you as her guy and then
you betrayed her they see that they see
just you know I think it's a pride thing
yeah yeah like that guy tips so yeah
mine yeah they fucking fought over you
once you left doing so who are you gonna
go with next time we go back I think I
would go it's you know they're so
different the first one massacres me but
I like that I like has a you know uh
what the end I've never come harder but
the the other lady petite hands very
small she's so ferocious so that first
one really grinds like getting
masturbated by a child right just oh my
god little girl here just the thought of
that
fully erect but the the second lady was
a little more you know loving you don't
like that well it depends I mean I I
tend to feel like I rat if I had to pick
one all the time I would go for the
really aggressive you like to be hurt
you like to go a stop yeah you like that
that gives you joy during them as well
yes such joy I feel like the others if
it's less than that I always feel like
nothing's happening yeah yeah it has to
hurt to feel like something's gonna be
deep yeah so I feel that toothpaste if I
don't feel the Bern of Aquafresh it's
exactly like toothpaste yes it's exactly
like toothpick that's how you know it's
working because it burns your mouth yep
mmhmm yep hmm how do you like soft
touches though right I like puppy
touches I'm like a little puppy I don't
want to be hurt life hurts I don't need
to be hurt
life hurts I don't need to be hurt Jesus
you know what I'm saying
took it to a whole other place yes you
know what I mean I go to relax Jimmy I
don't need her to beat me up yeah you
know pombal me mm-hmm mm-hmm
I like my lady she's she's a little
chunky I got a little nervous when she
got on top of me I was like oh fuck this
big on top of me once you explained
yourself
well the Thai massage day today like sit
on you know she sits on my butt bones
they put their knees on news anything
and I got real nervous I'm like bitch I
just gave birth later you know almost
five months ago my body is not aligned
yet my my joints are still losing and
you know be sure to sandwich
I so sorry Itay I did gentle I'm doing
her accent I know I know how what'd she
say no seriously she does what she's hi
sovath I should I say segoe i annoy
beats i softly gentle high gentle gentle
she is she's tight and she and she is
gentle and she gentle and since she got
on my ass and I was like haha you know I
was nervous cuz she's real chunky you
like that but I like the buck bones
that's the best yeah that's good that's
my I wish you'd you like an hour of just
bub bones
you probably asked for it many cultures
all into just whatever you want and I
like to that there's no um modesty
it's not like a like a
like a super uptight white place yeah I
put your put these panties on you're
like come on yeah yeah I just get naked
and she grazed my mail last time a
little too oh really raised it was a
bomb really oh yeah yeah you don't want
to touch you know they gonna start razor
no no yeah does she graze your nuts the
nuts it's so it is a like I'll be really
relaxed and then I will get cuz they're
so aggressive with me that I go I could
really get a testicle hurt you know it's
not like oh it's like yeah ah so it's
like that's usually where my eyes start
to open
don't please my testicles with you oh
yeah they could I bet they have oh yeah
I Sai Bao what you're by I saw I graze
your bars like she said I don't say that
shit they never say that she doesn't
know balls
I don't know sorry yeah yeah it's no
sorry man
No